al azar retomó el control de grandes
áreas del país pero estados unidos a un
control las zonas petroleras y de
producción de trigo turquía domina cerca
de su frontera eso sin contar los
remanentes del estado islámico la guerra
ya terminó
y desangelada creo que todavía la de la
guerra no ha terminado
hay varias todavía enclaves las cuales
asad todavía tiene que recuperar tanto
en inglés como en el noreste controlado
por digamos los sectores kurdos por lo
tanto creo que todavía si bien estamos
entrando a la fase final
afortunadamente falta una serie de pasos
que tienen que ver con el arreglo
institucional de la silla tipo guerra el
cual parece ser bastante desafiante no
sólo por la intención de ver antes de
continuar el poder sino también por la
y complejidad de actores regionales e
internacionales involucrados después de
una década de guerra no solamente se
mantiene el dolor constante de la
mayoría de la población que ha perdido a
sus seres queridos también está ariel la
angustia de una crisis económica que
empeora los precios de los alimentos el
colapso de la moneda la escasez de los
servicios públicos y de la gasolina como
podrá bashar al-assad subsanar las
consecuencias del conflicto que no logró
sacarlo del poder
bueno creo que hoy en día más avanzada
tiene dos desafíos importantes además de
obviamente las consecuencias desde el
conflicto armado el primero tiene que
ver con la expansión del cob y 19 entre
poblaciones o está tensionando aún más
el débil sistema de salud y en segundo
lugar las consecuencias económicas de
una crisis de que se desarrolle en un
marco de una economía de guerra economía
devastada y esto creo que es
lamentablemente requiere que los todos
los actores involucrados y también los
organismos internacionales presionen al
gobierno de al assad para comenzar un
proceso de reconstrucción decidida que
va a ser una de las claves del de la
posguerra una vez que los conflictos del
conflicto interno finalice
pero todavía esta es una película que
está el final está por verse y
finalmente más de la mitad de los
ciudadanos fueron forzosamente
desplazados del país miles de
desaparecidos y más de medio millón de
muertos pero la justicia no llega para
ellos apenas hay una sentencia en el
extranjero por crímenes de lesa
humanidad como podría acabar este
estancamiento en la búsqueda de la
reparación para la gente
bueno soy bastante escéptico en relación
a que luego de este este largo conflicto
haya justicia
como lo vimos en otros conservados en
sus labios o en ruanda porque aquí el
sistema no ha caído no debemos pasar
avanzado y los principales componentes
de las fuerzas armadas y de seguridad
siguen en el poder entonces realmente va
a ser muy difícil ver a tenemos un
régimen que sigue en el poder y que
seguramente debido a que en definitiva a
pesar que está muy debilitado ha
triunfado en relación a los reveses de
diferentes grupos por lo tanto la verdad
es muy difícil que esto lleve demasiados
pasos más allá de lo visto hasta ahora